okay bring it in here let's take a look
at this cake yes i haven't seen the cake
yet myself by the way so 100 episodes
let's see what this thing looks like
who made it is this this one that adam
made or uh
look
it actually does look legit wow nice job
i like it adam what do you think that's
phenomenal happy birthday to us
happy birthday poopy pants
happy birthday
mickey got it let's do a hundred thank
you
mickey wow that is a beautiful cake
this this is the 100th episode the next
one that we're going to celebrate at
this level you know which one's going to
be the additional 0.
is it 500 or a thousand is that 500
i think you could celebrate five okay
we'll do it we'll do 500 we'll celebrate
go put that put the
do it let's see what's gonna happen here
we couldn't have caroline do this for
the views how did sam get this job
unbelievable yeah
the fact that sam isn't wearing a vest
on the 100th episode is actually
disrespectful extremely
extremely sound together
in the beginning nobody cares about that
but they care about his vest there he is
really sam hill put it together by the
way sam bring your haircut let's see if
we can get thumbs up or down come show
your haircut everybody he says he got
the ronaldo haircut can you show it to
everybody let them see it go a little
lower you need light look straight at
the camera look straight at the camera
okay
ladies he is not single okay
oh
is that official now
what's up sam you are single or no yes
you are oh
wait wait yes or no
what's happening
yes or no
okay complicated translation she listens
to the podcast
hi let's let's say hey let's sing happy
birthday and give away the plus day
playstation 5. it's the 100 up uh
episode that we're doing because i think
i don't know how long has it been is it
your what's the first podcast by the way
july i'm assuming yeah july i think you
guys started last year wow okay shout
out to our old friend jf
josh who loves you by the way comments
about your stuff all the time on three
one two three happy birthday to you
happy birthday to you happy birthday
dear podcast happy birthday to you yes
go ahead you want to blow or you want to
do this by yourself
am i going to blow on here bring it over
here hi this was fantastic all right so
we did uh we did joe biden now we're
doing kamala harris
all right there you go nice fantastic
guys here's to another hundred here's to
another 500 here so another thousand
good job where's willie
this was great this was fantastic tom
tom gerard ricky adam the last thing we
got to do is samvell come and tell us
and show us who's going to win the
playstation 5. this is your last chance
folks by the way a lot of good comments
here tonight about what uh today about
what the podcast is doing a couple
things i do want to tell you guys while
we're going through this we are in the
process of buying a building we were
going to buy two buildings one of the
offers the other guy came in and closed
i don't know what it was at 459 and if
that offer was gonna drop we're gonna
buy this building at 15 million bucks
but we did end up buying another
building and the new podcast set will be
coming out here soon pending uh a glass
showing up from china
which is a whole different count
literally
but
one of the things we're thinking about
doing with the podcast is we're going to
set up the a podcast set in a way where
we may do a live podcast once a month
where people can buy a ticket come and
actually watch the podcast live i think
that'll be real sick to have an audience
there doing it together and then uh we
may be going to three episodes a week
the key word in that sentence is a very
technical word it's man we made it going
and what we are talking what it means is
in
[Laughter]
but the biggest thing is we may test out
doing two the tuesday thursday episode
we may test out a friday afternoon
episode
for uh just to see how that's going to
do it it's going to be three or five or
four to six we don't know yet but we may
test out something that's going to be on
a friday afternoon go ahead gerard let
me ask you before you wrap up the
you're you're 100 episodes in is this
has this turned into what you expected
it to be what have you learned along the
way has the audience you've been there
like what yeah what's this experience
for you let me tell you what what i love
about what what happened tom you good
nothing you were making some weird
noises no it's like happy trails right
what was the journey but no i will tell
you this it's a great question i will
tell you that what what this has done
the podcast has done is it is created an
open platform for us to talk about real
issues that people are thinking about
but you're told by society that you
shouldn't talk about these things i like
talking about
stuff that people don't want to talk
about i'm interested in that and i think
these things we talk about there's an
audience for it the most important thing
about what we're doing is the fact that
there's an audience that wants to hear
this kind of discourse from a former you
know ricky aguilar who lived a different
life michoacan to now being a successful
businessman he and his wife run a very
successful multi multi-million dollar
year business for themselves from a
former
comedian kirk he's still a comedian but
a guy that worked on chris christie's
camp was a former professional athlete
fighter mlb
sitting here from jersey you're bringing
your opinions there tom zenner who every
time you talk to tom you learn something
new about the guy he was there for the
last dance at every single day you know
married guy with two kids from
california tom ellsworth who's been in
the uh
you know different industries with tech
has had many different successes strong
father strong family from a you know a
devout jewish handsome man who is a cat
supporter cat convention you know out
here was thinking about getting married
before 70 years old who has his own
strong opinions working on that we're
working on you are not working on that
man listen i am working on that
i i would put over under what that i
would actually put some money on the
over under for age i would put some real
money and if the wedding happens if i
lose i fund your entire wedding how
about that if i i will fund your entire
wedding if i get the age right okay
he'd get married what are you right now
what are you ready for the party 40
you're 40 right now yeah you get married
before 43 i pay for your wedding i'm the
type of guy that would get married just
to save that money you get very very sad
i do your wedding i do it at the house
i'll bring ya so i'll do anything you
want for you
now you're talking my language
ladies out there
can you imagine he actually gets married
before 43 and i'm at the wedding i'm
giving a speech i'm like listen i funded
this i made the biggest mistake saying
yes but anyways worst investment but
here's the thing everybody hang on a
second if it's after 43 then what what
do i get because that's what you got to
say to the public as well if it's after
43.
i only like one side of this equipment
it's not how this works
if it's not 43 what is it i guess i
gotta fund my own wedding
we got i'm a risk i got a risk here
because to me if you get i pay for
dylan's wedding when he when he grows up
have time to work on it's gonna be
pretty big but he's middle eastern it's
gonna be like a six hundred thousand
dollars
yeah okay all right so uh anyway who do
you think gets married first gerard or
me
or dylan
right
there we go
dylan ah
who do i think between you and him
i'm probably going gerard yeah really
yeah i am but but for different reasons
i'm going with gerrard okay and i don't
think neither one of you guys want to
get married any time you do want to get
i would put your money on me over gerard
i don't know i don't know someone's
gonna have to agree to marry that guy
you gotta understand i think there's a
there's a line i think there's there's
plenty of people that are man
here's that case study time baby
all right bust out that uh
on that calculator we're gonna put some
degrees on this side i guarantee i just
can't i guarantee you he's done more
research on that than you have i
guarantee you he has the field research
predictive analytics at seven minutes
and 48 seconds the biz dog has pulled it
off the biz dog babe is dope she's great
she's cool you out kicked your coverage
buddy
fyi every night his kids call him just
to talk to him before he goes to sleep
no matter what part of the world is in
this guy's a winner at the highest level
yeah because they want to get you on
i tell you one other thing about this
whole uh this whole uh uh thing with the
podcast is you
don't have to interview
somebody that's like it's just we're
coming together as friends and having
conversations together okay what are you
thinking about it so
uh pretty excited about the next thing
we're doing some of the uh announcements
that we'll be making here soon going to
be exciting but this is what we're
releasing can we give a shout out to the
production team over here eric david
jorge they did a great job they did a
great job like sam made it happen today
six of us i know they put a lot of work
in here i got a shout out today paul got
a shout out for the fish tom gave you a
nice little shout out about you fish
shout out bring your fish but yeah
team did a great job everybody did a
great job thank you for your help so if
you enjoyed this little short segment
from the podcast that we did here's
another short segment to watch or if you
want to see the entire podcast click
over here take care everybody bye-bye
[Music]